rené désir marilou craintes et will
prosper à travers leurs gestes leurs
mots et leurs histoires
ces afro descendants font bouger les
choses en racontant le réalité de
québécois pure laine fine à montréal
j'ai grandi à laval dans un quartier
super blanc puis j'ai vraiment une
expérience de porc ressembler
physiquement ou monde qui m'entoure
angres enfin cette identité métissée et
la revendique
et la célèbre dans ses écrits et ses
prises de parole mais il est vrai que ce
ne soit plus un carcan beaucoup donc
vous entendre à mon identité que j'ai
pas l'impression de pouvoir explorer
pour sa part rni désir travaille à la
création de nouveaux spectacles
documentaire sur l'histoire des noirs à
montréal souvent on a des prises de
position on a nos convictions
mais ce qui vient nous faire flancher
des fois c est qu on arrive à toucher la
fibre émotionnelle dont clara cette
baguette magique qui nous permet de
rentrer dans ces espaces là et moi c'est
ce que j'utilise
elle s'inspire de trois histoires dont
celles de marie josèphe angélique une
esclave accusé d'avoir mis le feu à
montréal en 1734 torturés pendus et
brûlé sur la place publique un des
éléments que j'utilise c'est bien sûr le
mur donc l'extrait que j'ai fait mais ce
mur de la résistance ce mur que le
peuple peut venir créer aussi pour dire
ça suffit en bloc et l'oeil faut que ça
change mais également ce mur qu'on
retrouve face à la résistance qui ont
envie de l'oppression
[Musique]
dans le documentaire knb jusqu'à la
victoire
présenté sur le site de l'om f où il
prospère nous fait découvrir le
montréalais d'origine haïtienne allait
filer tête
c'est l'histoire d'un simple citoyen
mais qui est extrêmement riche parce que
cette personne là tellement philosophie
a tellement sage et c'est tellement
d'humanité aussi qu'on finit par tomber
véritablement en amour avec un étranger
et si on est capable de tomber en amour
avec un étranger dans un film on devrait
le faire avec notre voisin notre voisine
où ils prospèrent crois que le mois de
l'histoire des noirs continuent d'être
rendez vous essentiel
ça nous met dans une position en pack
percement de dire mais on a contribué à
cette société là aussi et pour les
personnes qui sont des personnes dans
des personnes moment reçu ça leur permet
de voir armée d'enfants
on a beaucoup plus de points en commun
qu'on pourrait le penser chacun à leur
manière
il est vrai par l'art à forger une
société plus inclusive et s'il a dit
alexandre chartier radio canada montréal
dandy rêve la nuit exilés de ton niveau